she's totally gonna flunk us I haven't
gotten an F since I failed recess in
second grade teachers need a break - Amy
you wanted to see me captain
my husband's dog shed her had relations
with a neighbor dog karate and produced
these two smaller dogs he insisted that
I find them a good home with someone we
trust you can trust me dogs are my whole
life also work doing work and hanging
with dogs
that's my lifestyle you're allergic to
dogs aren't you nope
I just need a pen because my happiness
is picking my throat close up hand me
the small dog Santiago Dew bottles of
vodka is this gonna be the weekend we
finally meet six-drink amy
six-drink amy what does that mean it's
the pinnacle of the Santiago drunkenness
scale one drink aim is a little Spacey
wait what two drinks
loud Amy you want to get a cab
three drinks Amy dance pants four-drink
amy is a bit of a pervert hey check it
out
and five-drink amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man but I've never
seen
six-drink amy maybe she's the one I
could actually be friends with aka I'm
so cold even my fiery dance moves aren't
keeping me warm
the trick is are you wearing t-shirt I
only brought a bikini it seems weird to
be in front of the captain in bathing
suit got to cover up them bangs yeah fYI
you can still see them for your shirt
that's a nice lamp job this one goes on
the blog hmm hey Sarge what up bro
what up bro bang all right Ames a nice
hmm you don't want to be around Holt in
your current state say hello to the most
confident woman alive yeah drink number
five you are a true friend and a hot
little piece good-bye four-drink amy
sloppy sicko
I love paperwork but this is crazy
there isn't even time to savor it
Charles you're going too fast I have a
choice we can't let this place for
fellowship perps yeah but you're gonna
cramp you kiddin baby I've been cramming
for the past 20 minutes
so attracted what nothing I'm gonna go
over to there now Jacob what's going on
why is Amy's hair like that
oh she obsessively braids her hair when
she's nervous and she's super nervous
cuz she's taking the sergeant's exam
today but Amy close tests not this one
it's always been her plan to be the
youngest captain in the history of the
NYPD but if she doesn't pass this exam
she's gonna have to wait another three
years to take it again and that'll
disrupt her entire life calendar is that
a real thing hit eggs over our bed
so she's stress breeding big deal it's
like one on the Santiago panic scale
yeah but we've also jumped up to level
two creepily singing songs from the
Great American Songbook so yeah it's a
little tough right now but I think the
worst is behind us why are you taking so
long my freakin oatmeal yikes where's
Teddy he's in the shower I said hi to
him we chatted for like a minute and I
almost blew it I'm sure you're
overstating that he said he was really
looking forward to a romantic evening
and I panicked and yelled lol okay we
have got to explain this thing to
captain Holt to save their relationship
and you laughed at me when I went to
that weekend long math conference
because you called it funky cats and
they're feisty Steph's that was the name
it was so cool it was not anyway it's
not about the math they haven't seen
each other because of the night shift I
just need a bone what gross Rosa
those are our dads I mean that's not
what I think captain dad is just my boss
Wow never mind I'm teaching father the
math whatever Rosa who's ready for some
non-stop totally scheduled fun oh I
actually thought we could just sit by
the pool you don't
shrimp and see what it does to our
bodies that's cute
I don't know if there's gonna be time
though the cruise offers 77 activities
and I signed us up for 76 of them
speed-dating for widows seem like a
bummer okay it's time for what detectors
I do go you to give me a promotion and a
40% raise I've been carrying the squad
for two years and my back's getting
tired yeah excuse me captain hey Mimi
can I talk to you for one second uh you
just did burn oh so good so listen I
don't think overconfident Amy is working
out maybe you should go back downstairs
oh maybe I should just have another
drink get ready America here comes Rick
oh hey that's Santiago I'm on the phone
I'm so sorry sir I can come back later
no it's too late the call is ruined
goodbye dear what do you want well since
there's a good chance of things are
coming to an end I just wanted to say
thank you for everything that you've
taught me I know you may not see
yourself as my mentor but of course I do
I've been mentoring you all this time
this is day 1280 two of a nine-year
mentorship I had mapped out for you
under ordinary circumstances I wouldn't
reveal this to you until day 33-hundred
it was real there was a vibe
not anymore no you can still mentor me
if we don't work together we could mera
breakfast every day you could teach me
over eggs thanks for breakfast further
behind and I thought ah no look okay
there are ten hours left sir
if you talk fast enough you can teach me
everything interesting okay you have to
take notes do you think you can keep up
let's just say I was president of the
stenographers Club in high school for a
reason was the reason because you were
the only member yes
Oh alone Oh No six-drink amy isn't fun
she's just sad damn it
get hold to pay attention to me it sure
spends a lot of time on Peralta maybe I
should start screwing up like Jake does
I can act out too you know please do
okay watch this
I don't understand what is happening
allow me to explain
Amy and I were ahead of you the whole
time
no you weren't part of this get back
over to the losers side loser right
worth a shot so how did you pull it off
well it all started when I went to tell
Jake how badly hurt my feelings and he
yelled at my breasts oh boy I'm not
gonna come off well in this story nope
remember when you set off the witch made
captain Holt flinch which was weird
since his door was closed but not weird
since he actually heard it over a bug he
planted at your desk it was in an old
muffin that you never threw in the trash
that's why people throw away garbage how
are we together anyway
I tapped into the bugs frequency so I
had ears on Jake I need to know what
Holt was up to that's where Hitchcock
came in I masterminded the entire plan
you did one small thing and I had to
explain it to you like 45 times he lost
a tiny crack in the blinds so I could
read the captain's lips Sharon and your
kids will distract Jake they'll be here
at 9:30 sharp my waffle xylophone on the
Cheeseman well my lip-reading is not
flawless now that I knew your plan it
was simple to disrupt while Scully
gracefully moved the witch I got into
character holt triggered the witch which
brought Jake into the room and I threw
the crown in the trashcan exactly as I
planned then I sent you all here placed
an out of order sign on the perfectly
functional elevator made you all walk up
31 flights of stairs and vomit twice
actually it was four times if you count
all the stairwell stuff you thought I
was just holds Lackey and you thought I
was just Jake's girlfriend well I'm my
own person
capable of making my own decisions and I
decided to humiliate you both well you
did and it was awesome one last question
where's the crown oh it's at Shaw's bar
the official site of my coronation
all hail the crown of Destiny and all
hail she who wears it Amy Santiago
the Queen Queen of the nine-nine I
believe there's something else you both
need to say gladly Amy Santiago is an
amazing detective-slash-genius
you